[Music]
located in a waterfront park known as
Gardens by the bay is super tree Grove
this mechanical forest is a utopia for
nature in a very urban location super
tree Grove was commissioned by the
Singapore government with the intention
of raising the quality of life for its
residents by enhancing greenery and
flora in the city this man-made
mechanical forest consists of 18 super
trees the trees range between 80 to 160
feet high and are connected by a walkway
which allows visitors to cross between
them and view the city from the treetops
with their thick trunks and network of
thin mehron like branches
each tree acts as a vertical garden
[Music]
over 160,000 varieties of orchids ferns
and other climbing plants have been
planted in the trees the trees also
generate solar power 11 of the trees are
fitted with solar photovoltaic systems
that convert sunlight into energy this
provides lighting that allows the trees
to come alive at night making this an
all day all season horticultural heaven
[Music]
you